you know sellers don't for hip-hop
another 92 3 baby it's the real after
party blue like Kevin DJ damage and
damage is excited because he finally has
somebody else from Philadelphia here
okay bro my boy can't be rock and to
build all the way from Philly what up
bro
Oh millionaire Bob and then sue me in LA
with it yeah man like LA - yes marijuana
yeah right yeah yeah you go to the
dispensary San Diego we drove from San
Diego over - oh well we're possibly
working with that I don't I don't wanna
[ __ ] up this guy's name simple x10 see
on the pacion look a little bit spanish
in there make sure just to call
extension that should be it but we made
it up the people made that Irish mats me
but are you working with him yeah
definitely he got a phone card I want to
do this no more um he will be given the
remix today well I want to get into
remix and we just that's got nothing
going - yeah hell yeah
I heard the remix every everyday we live
right with it yeah Wiz is on there baby
can you tell me should I come about a
made the first one or a remake of a
remake the first one came about man we
just me a wife in which is out uh losing
man hey um he was already here to show
and I was out there I had a show you
know us we we always had to do something
we had to figure it out from your nose
at the perfect time they're like yo
initial gang like yfn be they're
definitely in the game city are we let's
get it we got right in the studio you
saw me came out where every day really
it was just a fob you said me was just
like we were no he's each other energy
and what about the remix the remix came
about marriage it was like the ball was
rolling on the first song he told me why
not give it a fire remix with Wiz
Khalifa and yadi like to the most mean
influences people in the game right now
I'm supposed to read with Wiz yet all
the time every time I link over where we
got a couple songs man was we get
literally he got that KK that's a whole
different type of we hang with them know
like for Marshall we everyday bra smooth
Lisa every daily
do you like you like dad nah let me says
that's so you you probably couldn't hang
with now because I'm working we do you
fill members I'm a smoke until I can't
anymore but I think I could even Gavin
it's kind of crazy
uh I stay in my lane you mean like
anyone just because he's the a below me
I got no you ever do the edibles no I
don't like the body I like a lady okay
can we write not a body having some
passed out Malaga I threw up my head
like alright go up how are the ladies
out here man I like which I've just
period you got me right here probably
slaying all day right do the heavenly
for having fun we've been having fun
with this formula are you being careful
you're not being reckless because you
know these holes are down to put your
bottle or reverently careful you for me
we just we just we just taking phones
left and right the [ __ ] alone finger
with the free tax no internal yeah I'm
on cameras one lady that's what you're
gonna [ __ ] to be bedded me up right keep
someone falling on holiday you are who
create you I do have a question though
this is all this some real jury inquiry
I have because damage always tells me
about Philadelphia I've only been to
Philly on a train from DC to New York
and it just looked terribly ER what was
the name of that city outside Chester
with white shuttle
oh [ __ ] row like blue does it look good
yeah it looks like like a war zone that
thing leaning um but he said it like
it's a thing for like people to just
like like yo like you and your boys
would be kicking it damage says he's
actually done this before we're like yo
plasma the next people who get off of
the train we're gonna just get off of it
myself
maybe like no [ __ ] nobody's [ __ ]
people up for no real pic oh my god you
could be walking down the street you're
here and [ __ ] like body maybe like you
know something about that [ __ ]
sister but knew you would be a good not
me tell you a real story I'm bringing
360 it was so bad where the mayor had to
step in it's not good I was all seeing
it I was all seeing in trying to go to
in China tell kids stop beard we gotta
stop flashmob yeah oh yeah yeah oh you
come up the relays mom said it was gonna
be a what it was really like going crazy
beef were you ever a victim of one of
these red beans feeling rotten [ __ ] you
know no one definitely no it's kind of
like random a fight hey random ass was
gonna add me crazy servants out add
their baton is selling Jeremy Thomas
Schelling damn have ever seen allen
iverson like like drunk out somewhere I
feel I could be some very common out one
time you'll be able to grow and we drove
so I'll grab some cream on bikes
Michael tickling it like when y'all were
kids what where we drove you're like
Mary Jo CA eyes creepers we didn't know
they soon rule it was crazy it was like
a two hours Mike right now everybody
said I added my own personal experience
but you know you me a is not as warm and
welcoming as you think it would be never
really medium you feel like like oh no
like you ever met him actually not what
about like Cairo and he'll go no no no
no anybody from that old Sixers team
just like wandering the streets like I
don't think things was fun foodie no
would you wander the streets if you
played on a Philly to I probably would
want to I would never go to Philadelphia
like come on I mean after everything you
tell me you make enough this guy makes
Philadelphia like the worst places I'm
from Phoenix Arizona
you got just letter yesterday right
y'all got some [ __ ] out there cuz
there's some hoes in Phoenix is that it
is a pig's [ __ ] pork yes we don't this
yeah don't miss no mrs. Knight so what
is the out when y'all go to a new city
I'm just curious like what is like the
source of most of like the chicks you
like is it get checked at the ends
social media yes it is very snapchat
games you nominee area be no fun in the
gang in town a whoever if they know that
you be with me getting to know yo man
the record you did with uh with Kodak on
the the horses records explains a bogey
yeah how'd you get on the theory hate
soundtrack I think it's some numbers
pretty monsters because like I got the
hooks right now do that
our hooks the firehose Mike Carroll
trekker like Karen knew that he sent
some beats over to my man Orlando
Orlando sign me correct black a boogie
xxx said he found a lot of months focus
but he just had the beat for the
soundtrack you mean like I did the hook
to one of them to gang up hook that was
the first one I did write the Ganga put
it was [ __ ] with the old day they
sent the other one the horses beat and I
did that I was thinking was just when
you meet and he it was like we need
features on them like we gonna put some
features on every couple my [ __ ] in
here like some [ __ ] die [ __ ] me a
boogie and Kodak blade was perfect you
Summerfest that's the most why right
there anyway that's how them songs came
about pretty much I like that man like I
feel like this new wave or artist that
we got right now everybody's linking up
everybody's cool with each other you
know a boogie do a lot of records
together like why do you feel like that
energy is coming in the hip hop now I
don't know me I was like I feel like we
got like the thing we're like two older
people like me be hating so much oh yeah
it's like we got your bird evolution see
something like we got it
so I'm like it's a new wave of music
like how long people first started
rapping like people looking at them
different from because it was a
different sound like people wasn't
rapping less [ __ ] would look down upon
it like how how they tried to us you for
me so it's like the same thing so we
just stick together with the city from
you all the nuweiba [ __ ] I got
the same type of energy same vibes just
going crazy on the strings we don't even
need like the radio or nothing it's just
like we just been going by fly yesterday
I got two gold records no radio that's
so crazy congratulate took you oh like a
while to get the debut project out
because I know you've been like grinding
for a few years man I was seeing you
doing your thing for a few years what
what was like like the the pressure of
putting that first project out with so
much anticipation and you know obviously
you know you've been making your famous
way for a while so was there a lot of
pressure putting that out I pretty much
was just me getting the right body and
work to go you for me like I have so
many songs like and I make so much music
it me just like man [ __ ] with this
little what are they gonna be as a whole
yeah for surely I can't just put out a
project and it don't make sense for me
like I got it like had the title gotta
make sense that every song got to
coincide with the title you got it like
best mitt I feel like that's what is
missing from the new generation is like
giving the [ __ ] about
consistency with the music life's like a
fool out in like when people like
there's putting out songs for SoundCloud
or for like stream you know like they're
not worried about their first out like
their album you know what I'm saying
like it's just thrown together it feels
like there's no continuity throughout
the project you know what I'm saying
it's like back in the day you listen to
Matic you're gonna fill you get a whole
story behind asses I fight everything
that I put out like as far as project
water you like I gave you like a Fame
yeah you get something out of me from
like it's not like you just doesn't feel
like a bunch of random songs it's like
majority my [ __ ] like everyday life [ __ ]
like a little [ __ ] [ __ ] you film like
today everybody going through gold
emotions for me you do got the hooks
right now thanks and you're emerging in
the scene who are some artists you would
love to do a hook for man some artists
you looked up to when he was coming up
sure I would love to someone like a foot
like a mary j blige there you go
you mean like a [ __ ] she she could use
it right now - she did it man like I
[ __ ] where everybody my mom listen to
everybody like media music hey so you
mean like I do a song with [ __ ] you
think you could revitalize any singles
career with a hook
can i yeah come on rock god I got the
golden hooks brother you get a hook I
could bring anybody back from you did
your hand it just any much that's what
it is register hooks they got a favorite
rapper all-time he magaz he put beans in
my top five why are you me I mean I
guess I'm Megan I'm an egg but it's like
these deadly deserves it doesn't deserve
to be in the top five all-time but who
you know better who wants a medal
register don't some battle rapping [ __ ]
who got harder bars and be harder [ __ ]
who got harder bars on the battle
rapping any time you got an exit
question is 50 times the assaut
Carnivale a city cassidy kappa awesome
nah I got it free way you're buggin the
way you got it free way what happenes
don't know but if there are videos
talking on bantling on video he's been
know what I'm saying we're selling my
own tricks no you said battling yeah
battle [ __ ] okay the bad ones oh I don't
know Jada I would fully bliss I'm fully
well versed in the Jadakiss beanie sigel
saga baby's delivery Larry I know for
sure
hell yeah as a rapper you can't say
beans is not one of the most amazing
money online okay
I'll take that I'll take a point of you
have hit 18 years he's like - 17 to 20
bracket I still heavy brains voice like
incredible more I mean I think beanie
sigel
could have been I mean you know his
first three albums like we're [ __ ]
incredible
who else can jump on a Cisco track and
say one of the heart is very listen and
be humble
it was incredible at least a dragon it
was like how many people you know get on
the study will know that is rapper ever
from Philly black stop yeah that's
that's not your job
are you like guys are long broad black
[ __ ] come on likely at 12 roots albums
are you kidding mirok li Leroy is
amazing but when you want to say best
rapper I'm going with delivery boys I'm
going with everything for Sonic
I'm going with B yeah it is what it is
sorry to have that's your opinion
a friend of y'all yeah my music is all
opinion you're adding in who's about
who's the best MC ever from Philadelphia
p.m. ever from Philadelphia yeah I'm
gonna agree with broke me
he got longevity with the city lately
already with the [ __ ] Lisa WC not right
date all around John was I do not just
hip-hop man or like they do every
[ __ ] thing like that I mean I mean
but there let me be black fathers
rapping on the high selling Black
Thought bro
black shot is oh hey made of he's the
man well he still in the mix we gotta
bring this full circle and let's try to
make the PMB rock beanie sigel
resurrection happen because I like me
anything I'm a fan I suck with beans I
just you know seven I'm qualified to
talk about anyway oh yeah I remember
seeing that yeah so look man the album
is out is dope yo the single is [ __ ]
killing us like 15 million [ __ ]
YouTube views yeah congratulations man
what what has been like I think like the
last three or four months it's been
super hot out here for you have you kind
of noticed like a difference when you go
out or when you uh like interact with
other artists the way they treat you
because I feel like you're in another
space then you were maybe like four or
five six months ago you know you
definitely change the same
the same thing you the same two things
you just say I noticed a change in both
of those you feeling like as far as like
when I go out now like as opposed to be
couple months ago when I come to LA like
few people might knew me but not like a
lot of people in there like as soon as I
jumped off the plane like [ __ ] like you
show me everybody like you want you mean
like it's different you show me just
like I'll line up a plane and I leaned
into San Diego Bryce is like well
[ __ ] knew who I was in San Diego
that's crazy
yeah and then like not in the right with
different artists and [ __ ] like as
opposed to me interacting months ago you
feel like muffled it's more like more
interactive like yeah we definitely got
get it we're now you know being that you
are you know jumping on anglesey fresh
in but it's a new experience what some
of those things you see in the industry
that you kind of not messing with like I
don't like how they doing that and I
like how people move in this way oh
that's why one thing that I don't like
like [ __ ] just wanna ride the
wave like a [ __ ] charge it like
just like a [ __ ] like takes an
ultimate wave rider just like a fellow
person I like traffic where everybody
did I [ __ ] with like if I had it I never
leave me a lot of people so when I meet
or not when I come across are that I
[ __ ] with I'd be hoping I get a goodbye
lineman target on there should be just
like everybody waited [ __ ] be on
time you fear and [ __ ]
no I get one a couple more folders with
genuine and thorough but a lot of the
time the [ __ ] just be like in
the own way and then soon as you start
popping off like yeah then they come
around people be dealing me muffled
explain oh how to [ __ ] I don't even know
how I'm off with a certain well forgot
my number like [ __ ] be texting
me separately
well we won't put those guys on black
yeah no no I'm never going what I like
to be who you you did mesh with that
were a hundred from the jump
you know like who are some artists that
you really [ __ ] with you know inside of
the game stuff like there's always a lot
of a credit always show me dumb low sure
that's one of them he needs one right
now like study our foot with a boogie
for sure like we always have ain't a
energy you feel me like a clean cold egg
black everybody off with like the new
up-and-coming beer anyway like Miyata
judaism or [ __ ] like anybody that i
reached out to like as far as like the
young [ __ ] like they [ __ ] with
the wavelength but the older
like the people that's like been in the
game like with longevity the ones who
like like being seized
did you see the Joe Biden little yachty
interview I think some of it now if Jill
Biden hit you up for a hook how much
would you charge him I was hurting what
I'm charging everybody
oh no there's no difference like you
wouldn't I be in charge you mutlar just
toss it high enough I feel like fire
anybody like that's one look that I'm if
I feel like I'm a charge yeah I mean
like I don't really [ __ ] with you like
that you feel me like I won't charge
everybody for guitars like the people
that I don't know because you never know
you might not [ __ ] with the people thank
you freezing
I'm sorry some of the people that don't
[ __ ] with but like a majority Tommy not
no no yeah I ain't got no relationship
with a person like I don't owe nobody
nothing you for me like we doing this
business if you look out for somebody
with a hook later on when you do a
project you would get them on it you
know it's kind of like a that's
different yes that's the relationship
with the person I guess stuff we got a
we got a bill get up you feel me
straight up man you know what are you do
are be cats that are that are kind of
you know like we're very relatable to us
you know like Street dudes and these are
kind of like hip-hop dudes as well like
whether it's black or yourself or or
Bryson what do you relationships like
with those guys because I feel like
there's just a new wave of just dope so
full street music coming out right now
yeah I never met Bryson but I feel like
like his energy probably be on the same
type of habla he clean with the cool
dude
who else we got like on the same type of
like black I don't know I never met him
but is fired to stay uh Kyle it neva
blocked off like when we come across it
so this is gonna be Lexus I mean goodbye
yeah I know Paso yes he do oh yeah there
been a random City you've been to on the
tour that like you didn't expect to be
as turnt as it was rookie houses in
Milwaukee no why how long is down man
toward I'm alright now both of the
motion tour it's been all ages but
Milwaukee was the only show that I had
it was like some reason it was 23 and
older 23 my Larry cut my vein like oh we
a Milwaukee like 22 years like when I
got like the majority you
I'm feeling like it's like a lot of kids
[ __ ] my suit might upset when I had
that show I was like kind of scary like
Danny's might not be lit that's it was
old dealer and all the [ __ ] were
singing my song like we really liked all
the 20 old girls I'm like damn this is
Ola like you know every song word for
word I got like I was home you think
he'll is likely a definitely like I was
surprised they Milwaukee out with the
[ __ ] over here yeah no yeah look man we
appreciate you coming through rockin
with marriage they still having me
character can be rock the Alma shout
what now you could go scoop that thing
up there are copies no I whisper not
even at the shows nah hey man you never
know it could come go on Ryan Apple
music in a downloaded you know buy it
first of all preferably buy it off of
the iTunes there are only curated
because all this [ __ ] ain't up to me so
maybe like so I want talk about the
about the glue crazy and self-possessed
about the glow that selfish is adding I
saw a fire Lucy there bro what made you
will rock with Empire because right now
Empire is kind of like the new
independent just rugged man it go crazy
it's like I've seen what they do for
artists and what they do for singles
project they go hard with issues like
like I you're like better than any other
major really for like a new audience if
I want to know what I know now I would
have [ __ ] on from the gumbo Woodlands
just wanted you know what's he doing and
he's doing all the right [ __ ] and they
got all the same the same connections in
these oh yeah same business relationship
partnership break oh yeah Empire
imma let you introduce the single man
let's get into this selfish or play a
man oh you should bleep Andy Rock and
right now but listen to my hit single
I'm selfish yeah we're still babies to
an after-party right 92 3
I want to a lot on myself you don't need
nobody up I want to honor microfiber
[Music]
yeah yeah now about it I was so hard on
my doubt by player you don't need nobody
else I swear I watch a lot of myself
because I'm selfish